she is sharing her experiences as a
mother and a new book whoa baby
a guide for new moms who feel
overwhelmed and freaked out Kelly
Rowland thank you for coming and joining
us and scaring me I'm gonna be a new mom
congratulations thank you I'm terrified
and your book made me even more scared
but it is the dose of real talk yes
where there's not a lot of real talk
what I want the book to be you know what
I wanted it to be everything that I felt
like I needed after I had my son and I
wanted it to be completely black and
white like no gray area and we talked
about everything it wasn't just me of
course it's my OB Jen dr. Tristan
Bickman that's involved in law mostly I
couldn't do it without her and we had a
lot of fun you know I had a physical
therapist involved some girlfriends of
mine back home who were very smart and
very successful in their fields Jules
and Esther and a friend of mine who's
also a psychotherapist Jo Bo Duke so it
was it was really a lot of fun like
really getting everybody to to get all
of their knowledge together and put it
all in this book for the moms and what
did you post on Instagram what did I
post on it which gets us on a good
talking point here you posted a picture
of yourself in his room you look
fantastic thank you also stretch marks
in this photo yes which is not something
we see on women ever right let alone
women who have been pregnant yeah why'd
you post the photo um it was first of
all I saw this amazing video and heard
this amazing song by Kendrick Lamar
titled be humble and he was this he's he
quotes and says um show me something
natural like and some stretch marks and
I was like well okay and I was like you
know I first of all a lot of a lot of
women are like oh my god I'm so just I
don't want to see stretch marks and I
have stretch marks that it's something
that we usually kind of a fight with
within ourselves and I just wanted to
bring light to it and just let women
know we all have them especially after
pregnancy yes Kelly it's a great book it
really is because it's it's um
it's based on we wrote it with
obstetricians go through a lot of stuff
that you say that nobody tells you which
still to this day after having three
children I'm amazed that this stuff
isn't taught in school or talked about
thank you yeah more openly so what you
what are your chapters
that you say you became obsessed with
breastfeeding - I really was because I
saw so many women do it you know whether
it was in public or you saw them do it
in the hospital rooms you saw it on
movies it just looks so beautiful and
glamorous and I was so excited about it
and it was one that I actually struggled
with and there was a beautiful lactation
nurse by the name of Linda Hana who
really helped me out she was like a
goddess she floated on air she came in
and as soon as she touched me I was like
so much flow and I just felt so motherly
but yeah it didn't last really long for
me and my supply was short and I
remember I felt and put a lot of
pressure on myself because I couldn't
supply as much as I wanted to and I had
to supplement and got to go to the other
yeah you got postpartum depression well
that is a really great chapter is one of
the chapters I'm most proud of in my in
my book a great friend and therapist of
mine Jo Bo Duke who actually helped me
write it he was just talking about the
women who feel a lot of shame you know
about postpartum depression and I'm so
happy that more moms different celeb
moms are opening up and talking about it
because it opens up room for dialogue
and it opens up room for communication
and us to be able to feel comfortable to
where there are any signs then we're
able to say you know what enough am I am
I you know weird or this for feeling
that and you're like no let's talk about
it and let's get somebody in father's do
you feel like it's it could be you know
more even more challenging for you just
makes you feel comfortable there's a
whole industry around pregnancy in the
way there wasn't even ten years ago
right look at women when they're
pregnant bump alerts yes and then
there's a snap back how fast do you get
your post baby body do you think there's
too much pressure on new moms physically
in terms of getting their bodies back
into shape after pregnancy I think so I
mean I remember for me I had but I put
the pressure on myself I must you know
you saw all these great moms who were
just bouncing back so fast and I'm like
how did she do it yeah and I'm looking
at like my pictures before I had my son
and putting that pressure on myself and
kind of rushing myself and someone told
me in that time they were like it took a
child ten months just about to form in
your body give yourself some time and it
was about a year that it took me to lose
the weight I
getting almost 50 pounds looks amazing
thank great information thank you so
much thank you so much